>> THE BEAUTIFUL FREEDOM TO HAV
HER THERE.
THE WHITE HOUSE FINALLY
ADMITTING THEY'RE AFRAID TO LET
PRESIDENT BIDEN SPEAK TO THE
MEDIA.
>> HE GETS QUESTIONS NEARLY
EVERY DAY.
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING WE
RECOMMEND, A LOT OF TIMES WE SA
DON'T TAKE QUESTIONS.
BUT HE'S GOING TO DO WHAT HE
WANTS TO DO BECAUSE HE'S THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THEM ALL HE DOES TAKE QUESTIONS
FROM TIME TO TIME HE MOSTLY
LISTENS TO THAT ADVICE.
>> WHO MY TURNING THIS OVER TO?
THINKING THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MISTER PRESIDENT VERY.
>> THIS LAST QUESTION I'LL TAKE
HER I'M REALLY GOING TO BE IN
TROUBLE.
>> HE'S GOING TO GET IN TROUBLE
VERY CHANNON, I WANT TO GO TO
YOU, YOUR BRILLIANT REPORTER
ALWAYS ASKING THE TOUGH QUESTIO
TO MY QUESTION IS THE MEDIA
ALLOWED THIS TO HAPPEN.
HE STATES IN THE BASEMENT, I
REPORTED THERE MANY TIMES AND I
WAS HARD TO GET QUESTIONS INTO
THE PRESIDENT, SO ARE THEY TO
BLAME FOR THIS PROBLEM?
>> I HAVE TO THINK EVERY WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY AT SOME
POINT SECRETLY SAYS THIS TO THE
CELLS I WISH THEY WOULD NOT
ANSWER QUESTIONS BECAUSE THEN I
HAVE TO GO OUT THERE AND CLEAN
UP WHATEVER THEY SAY, BUT THIS
WHITE HOUSE LIKES TO BE PRETTY
CONTROLLED WITH HIM.
HE'S GOT NOTES, THEY ARE VERY
CAREFUL AND AS YOU SAID DURING
THE CAMPAIGN, THAT WAS SORT OF
THE TONE THEY CITE, BUT ONE
SOMEBODIES IN THE WHITE HOUSE
THESE REPORTERS WANT QUESTIONS
ANSWERED THEY WANT TO TALK TO
HIM DIRECTLY AND FRANKLY, WE GO
SPOILED DURING THE LAST OF
MINISTRATION BECAUSE PRESIDENT
TRUMP COULD NOT WALK TO MARINE
ONE WITHOUT STEPPING AND TALKING
.
SOMETIMES 20 OR 30 MINUTES TO
THESE QUESTIONS SO I THINK SOME
OF THESE PRESS CORPS FOLKS MAY
NOT ADMIT IT, BUT I THINK AT
LEAST WHERE THAT'S CONCERNED
THEY'VE MISSED THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND THAT ABILITY TO
ENGAGE WITH IMPAIRED.
>> LOVE OR HATE HIM, HE GAVE A
LOT OF ACCESS.
>> THIS GUY WAS ONCE AROUND THE
PRESIDENT UNITED STATES AS THE
GREATEST RETAIL POLITICIAN THEY
LOVED HIM OUT THERE TALKING WIT
PEOPLE.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> I THINK HE IS A GREAT RETAIL
POLITICIAN, BUT I WANT TO
REITERATE, I HAVE BEEN AT WHITE
HOUSE CORRESPONDENT AND ALL OF
MY ASSOCIATIONS WITH THE PRESS
SECRETARY NOT ONLY THE WHITE
HOUSE, BUT UP ON CAPITOL HILL,
TO THE HALL, STATE HOUSES,
CORPORATIONS, ALL PRESS
SECRETARIES WANT TO BE
GATEKEEPERS.
THERE IS TO MAKE THEIR PRINCIPA
LOOK GOOD.
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO IS THEY
WANT TO CONTROL THE TYPE OF
QUESTIONS AND THE ENVIRONMENT,
THEY DON'T WANT GOTCHA QUESTIONS
.
THEY DON'T WANT STUMBLES, THEY
DON'T WANT HIM UNPREPARED,
THAT'S WHAT EVERYBODY WANTS FOR
THE PERSON THERE REPRESENTING A
A PRESS SECRETARY.
I THINK IT HAS SOME ADDED MOMEN
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT THEY ARE
PERPETUATING THIS IDEA, BIDEN'S
AN OLD GUY WHO DOESN'T KNOW WHA
HE'S DOING, HE STUTTERS.
SO I THINK FOR FOR CURTIS AEI
THINK YOU AND I HAVE ISSUES.
I WOULDN'T GO THAT FAR, I JUST
THINK THAT ALL OF US HAVE OUR
MOMENTS AND PRESS SECRETARIES
THEY ARE LIKE MAKEUP ARTIST,
THEY WANT YOU TO LOOK GOOD.
>> THEY WANT YOU TO LOOK GOOD,
JESSE, BUT THE PROBLEM IS WHEN
YOU COMPARE HIM TO FORMER
PRESIDENTS, IT'S NOT QUITE
OPERATING THE SAME.
>> I DON'T EVEN NEED TO HEAR
FROM BIDEN AT THIS POINT, I
DON'T TRUST THE GUY, HE SAID HE
WAS A MODERATE AND THEN HE GOT
IN THERE AND HE BROKE THE BANK
AND THE BORDER.
I DON'T EVEN THINK DEMOCRATS
NEED TO HEAR FROM BIDEN PEER AT
HIS BRAIN TRUST IS RUNNING THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE BIG LOBBYIST
AND A BUNCH OF OTHER GUYS, THEY
MAKE ALL THE DECISIONS AND SUSA
RICE IS BASICALLY IN THERE TO
HAVE OBAMA HAVE HIS EYES AND
EARS ON THE WHOLE OPERATION.
THEY WANT THAT GUY SCRIPTED, HE
GOES OFF SCRIPT AND HE GOES INT
THE NEANDERTHALS PRETTY WAS
ASKED ABOUT IRAN AND CHINA THE
OTHER DAY AND ASKED LIKE LOOK
LIKE HE WAS HAVING A PANTS
ATTACK.
I THINK THIS COUNTRY IS
LEADERLESS RIGHT NOW COME OVER
AS SUPERPOWER, WE CAN COAST, BU
NOT FOREVER.
THIS GUY IS JUST A TAX-AND-SPEN
LIBERAL, HE'S NOT EVEN TRYING T
PERSUADE PEOPLE ANYMORE.
HE'S NOT INSPIRING ANYBODY AND
PROBABLY THE LESS HE SAYS THE
BETTER BECAUSE YOU KNOW ABOUT
WHAT HE'S DOING THE LESS YOU
LIKE IT.
WE ELECTED THE ANTI- TRUMP, OF
BORING LISTLESS GUY THAT STAYS
INSIDE AND DOESN'T REALLY CHARG
PEOPLE UP AND THEN IN FOUR YEARS
, WE WILL PROBABLY GET
BORED AND LIKE THE OPPOSITE
YOUNG CREATIVE PRISMATIC GUY
LIKE YOU.
>> THAT WAS GOOD.
>> JUDGE, I HAVE TO GO TO YOU
BECAUSE THE LAST CAMPAIGN WAS
ABOUT TONE AND PERSONALITY.
IT REALLY WASN'T ABOUT POLICY.
IT DOESN'T FEEL GOOD WHEN YOUR
TAXES THE BORDER IS OPEN, SO
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> THERE IS ALREADY BUYER'S
REMORSE EVERYBODY IS EVERYBODY
HE WANTS PERSONALLY, HE'S GOING
TO TAXES AND HE'S ALLOWING THE
SOUTHERN BORDER TO BE COMPLETEL
OPEN GUARD I WANT TO COMMENT
ABOUT ONE THING AND THAT IS THA
WE JUST HEARD PRESIDENT BIDEN
TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT HE WAS
GOING TO GET IN TROUBLE.
WHEN HE WALKED BACK TO THE
PODIUM HE SAID I'LL ANSWER THIS
QUESTION, BUT I'M GOING TO GET
IN TROUBLE.
YOU REMEMBER LAST WEEK WHEN HE
COULDN'T FIND HIS MASK HE WAS U
THEY'RE DITHERING AROUND ON THE
PODIUM LOOKING FOR HIS MASK AND
HE SAID I'M GOING TO GET IN
TROUBLE.
WHO IS HE GETTING IN TROUBLE
WITH?
THIS IS PROOF POSITIVE TO ME.
HE ALWAYS SAYS HE'S GOING TO GE
IN TROUBLE VERY FEW ARE YOU
GETTING IN TROUBLE WITH?
AREN'T YOU YOUR OWN MAN?
AMERICA KNOWS THAT.
>> HE GETS IN TROUBLE BECAUSE
WHEN HE'S AT THE BORDER HE ENDS
UP CALLING IT